how did you get involved with spare
change ok I'm going to try to give you
the most condensed version possible this
story so one of my good friends from
college with school in Cleveland was in
Chicago before me he lived or was
friends with another kid that went to
our college who grew up in Omaha
Nebraska the kid from Omaha Nebraska who
lived with this thought on let me I'm
trying to figure out the best way to put
this story all right long story short a
friend of a friend of a friend was
friends with my good buddy and then soon
to be roommate when I moved to Chicago
his older brother happen to be this
gentleman named Chris who coincidentally
when I had one of my first improv shows
in Chicago years and years and years ago
he was friends with the sister of a guy
that was in my group so he was like at
the show and then later that night
because I was friends with his brother
we were all like the same party and so
we met there and Chris actually set me
up with my firt because he's like oh you
did you were awesome you know because he
used to be an actor so he said I got to
set you up with my agent so greatest guy
in the world I knew him for one night
and he set me up to get an interview
with his agent literally that monday and
i went in and they signed me oh wow and
I had just gotten into everything when i
was there and then fast forward to LA he
was out here you know probably three
years before I was and he was just you
know working his in the.com world and I
worked on a couple web series that he
helped out on and did a couple guest
spots in and so he just kind of on the
business side had this idea he's like
you know all these people put X amount
of dollars into small digital work or
short form I think there's a way to you
know profit from it in the feature world
so let's see what we can do so call me
together like all right let's make a
movie here's how much money we know we
have he worked on a film in Chicago with
a guy named Jonathan Talbert on
Jonathan's first feature called
Nowheresville like 10 years ago in
Chicago who was now on orange is the new
black and worked with Netflix we wanted
to talk to him about distribution and
how that and that's changed drastically
over the past two years but how that
game in the digital world works and so
about an hour into our lunch she was
like when you guys shooting this that's
a great Jonathan impersonation you guys
don't know him it was perfect when you
guys shooting it and we told him our
shoot date we wanted to get it done by
you know the early of 2014 and he was
actually just getting off of orange is
the new black like right when we wanted
to start production so he's like do you
have a director yet because and then his
producing partner that he's worked with
on shorts and stuff Arturo who was also
in orange is the new black was kind of
doing the same schedule they both wanted
to come on so us for just kind of all
clicked but Arturo's from San Diego he's
not a Chicago guy he's not a Midwest guy
so he was the outsider but he's also one
of the greatest human being so those two
directed Chrissa handled the business
side and I was a producer having the
most creative side work from the Talon
and script and everything and did you
all of you see eye to eye on how you
would get the movie out there like did
you differ at any point like oh no let's
try for these big festivals not there
there there was but nothing it just if
something got vetoed or if there was a
majority vote it was just like okay
that's what we're doing there was never
really a fight we kind of all trusted
each other we know what we were all good
at what our best you know attributes
word to bring to the project so we kind
of left each other alone and whatever we
were doing so you know Chris does the
research and he you know got the funding
for it so we're gonna kind of follow his
lead you know we'll throw a little for
things here what we want to do and where
we think it could help but for the most
part you know we did nothing was decided
unless it was collectively though which
was hard to do when we're all working
different things now but what would you
say is your strong suit that you bring
to it aside from being funny and an
actor and charming I was gonna that's so
weird i was actually gonna say all of
those things it's a triple threat oh
okay don't you scratch that um i have an
eye for bringing in the right people
because it's if you bring in one whether
it's a cast member or a crew member you
know one grumpy Gus or someone who
doesn't want to be there someone's
negative it affects everybody it does
and you're stuck doing this and it's
always hot no matter where you are no
matter what production you're on your
it's always hot because you can never
have the air running if you're inside
and there's lights everywhere and
there's wire it's always
so everyone's already cranky everyone
always wants to know when lunch is
anyways so we bring in one bad person
that's not optimistic or as optimistic
or half full as everybody else and it's
going to break the house of cards a
little bit so bringing in from because I
had or we had excuse me think 73
speaking roles which for a small
independent film is a lot and you know
we auditioned for all of that it wasn't
just like hey I know you why don't you
come in and do this we wanted to kind of
cast a wider net and see you know give
other people an opportunity they may not
have had one to be in a film so it was
bringing in good people that were just
fun to work with and we're good at what
they do I was like you're really good at
knowing the right people knowing who
would work yeah and I like that putting
together you know building your own team
and the girl that wrote it Stephanie
math lists another comedy connection I
used to be in a group with this girl
Katie and she was best friends because
she went to college with this girl named
Stephanie who was now a writer in New
York and like a long time ago stephanie
was in town in Chicago because that's
where she's actually from and we met
like one night and then you know four
years later when I was looking for stuff
and just sending something out to
friends like if you know anybody we're
looking for scripts and Katie was like I
think you met Stephanie years ago she
has a strip because she used to be
managed by I won't say she's been
managed by you know XYZ but she's not
with them anymore would you take a look
at it and then I was like hey it's
awesome be I met her and I know she's
cool and see she's going to be willing
to work because the different business
when you're dealing with a small budget
you know you have to sacrifice a little
bit up front in the hopes that it does
well in the back
you